all right patrick
so nice to be here nice to see you again
how are things
what's going on well um
i'm uh so so when i
first came here that was what like a
month ago probably yeah yeah
so when you continue
to have like
the next crack hit be the only thing
that matters for
uh that long
it gets it it's insane
and uh that's that's where i'm at i uh
um
oh [ __ ] because our second talk you were
you were somewhat clean right
yeah or were you just broke you're broke
okay broke and so so therefore so this
has been extended
bender for you here it turned into one
yeah
turned into one um
not because of what i've given you no no
that's
that's like even though i have given you
some money yeah yeah
i appreciate that but that's like a you
know
a drop in how have you supported this a
tiny bit in the
ocean of uh yeah so this time
this has been the worst of all i uh
i sold my car oh no i sold my car
um that's what that's one of
the rules that that you're not supposed
to break you can always
get more crack or whatever you're trying
to do with a car
than the money that you get for selling
the car
ah this is here we go [ __ ] it this is
the fourth car
that i've sold to a crack dealer
um however it was 13 years ago that's
that i did the third one i you know i uh
you know and it
is crazy
like what you know i've had a couple
situations where
things went wrong things go wrong a lot
especially when there's a you know when
i'm with like a girl
smoking crap you know it's like oh here
have all my money that's kind of like
how
it goes um sometimes
and i find myself sitting here
just desperate you know it's four in the
morning and all of a sudden like
out of nowhere i don't know i had money
and out of nowhere like
i had no money no cigarettes no
uh no drugs nothing
and uh
it's like i go crazy i come back i come
back over here i drive back over here
and i just park
and uh it's like i have to have have to
get a crack hit somehow i have to
and um you know i was parked
like it was like you know i was parked
from like six in the morning until
nine in the morning in one spot just
sitting in my car and
down here skid row and and people were
like waking up you know like
almost like more people were coming
because it was the the day was starting
you know and a couple people came up to
the car got a cigarette like you know
and i realized that you know i'm
i'm drifting into this you know where
it's like the day starts and you have
nothing
and you gotta go around and figure out
how you're gonna get through that day
and you know what's more important than
drugs yeah that's the most not food
yeah see that's the thing i've
discovered recently
you know i do a lot of thinking about
this and i interact with a lot of these
people that are in situations
similar to yours maybe somewhere some
better but
the priorities are a huge consideration
like i'm a normie right so for me
love is your first priority love love i
would say i would say even if it's money
success
fame you know that's a good point you're
right you're so so whatever you think
your
your main priority is it's love for you
for yourself your fam
your loved ones for yourself or your
important people in your life for me
that's not that's number one
for an addict your priority is getting
the fix
so our our goals are not aligned so
we're never going to see eye to eye for
in any kind of relationship because
you're trying to get that fix and you'll
do anything to get it and you'll lie
cheat or steal and you'll deceive me or
you'll just
do whatever you need to you'll steal
from me or you'll do whatever to get
the fix whereas a normie would
whose first priority is is
love and that means probably being
honest and straightforward and all that
kind of stuff
yeah i i do think a little that i have
i don't know if it's a reputation but i
i think i'm probably the most honest i
was going to say that too
uh crackhead you are here you are
because because you've interacted you
and i have interacted several times now
off camera yeah and i never get the
feeling that you're just
trying to scam me like a lot of these
people are like pretty much all of them
are
for example let me give you an example
that day i sat over there
like how am i going to do it how am i
going to do it how am i going to do it
check this out
and i found in my in my uh
glove box yeah uh a starbucks
gift card for 25 right i'm thinking like
maybe i go to starbucks and ask the guy
the guy that has
the dealer you know that's over there if
he wants a coffee
i mean yeah or maybe i could maybe i
better go to him
and you know he could he could give that
as a gift you know when he goes to the
next family birthday party or something
that's what i'm thinking in my head so i
go up there
and i see him and he's right there on
the passenger side of my car
and of course he has no no desire for
this
the starbucks is not worth anything he
doesn't want it and it's like no
you know it's like nothing like i was
still not okay
he's not gonna give me anything it's
fine i get it
so watch this so he's there and as he's
also i'm up for three four days so i'm
like it's hazy
and that's also the case right now um
as he's walking away like i just saw
like as a glimmer
something kind of like like a shadow
fall you know
from him from like from his pocket and
he's walking away that way
and i waited i almost wasn't going to do
it then i went over and opened the
passenger door and looked
and it was a 20 bill on the ground all
right
what do you think i did
you bought some crack i yelled hey i
yelled at him oh i see
i yelled at him hey man you dropped 20
hey
hey hey you dropped this wow that's
impressive
he came back and picked it up for a
crack addict that's really impressive
i i wasn't i was desperate
you know but that's what i did yeah and
uh
he didn't you know i was like he didn't
really say anything but
but then he did give me a tiny
bit of crack you know like not twelve
not twenty dollars worth but
you know he he did that which was good
but i mean the beginning of your story
shows you how desperate
an addict can get yeah and he's and he
said
when i offered him the starbucks card uh
i want the car and i never heard that
from like
no in the and so and then the toilet
real thing happened i got
i got a little hit i drove away i didn't
take the hit yet
and i remember that i had the title to
my car
in the car which i did that because uh
sometimes you can get like like a loan
from that you know so
i was thinking maybe i could get some
money not
give the car away you can go get a title
loan or whatever
and i realize that and i was like he
wants the car here's the title
i turned around drove back down there
with the title in my hand
like like and uh
you know next thing you know like the
next morning he took the car
i you know i uh i said i said yeah
you know we agreed on a price
it was like you know i was i was uh
i was making sure to get more cash than
he wanted to give me he probably just
want to give me like all drugs
uh and i was like i need
i need to use the car until this is over
i can't be out here
you know the next morning ah
took the car and i and i i have no car
you know so i'm living in my apartment
which is turning into
it's just yeah i mean it's not it's not
that bad but
it's not about as bad as so your
situation now is worse than it was on
that first time
wait way worse yeah i mean it's like
it's like you'd stop doing anything
uh responsible and just smoke crack
and if you you know you do that for a
week that's really bad if you do that
for six weeks
that's probably not six times but it's
probably like
you know you know six to six power
times worse or whatever so um so what is
the solution
do you have any ideas i need like that
like i'm i'm
i need to go to rehab um
right now
i went to a rehab for detox and then
you know something something happened
you know something like just a tiny
little thing happen with the insurance
where it's like a little bit maybe
this isn't going to work out maybe you
know and i i
after like a little while not instantly
but after a little while
when it seemed like there was a
discrepancy that
uh you know shouldn't have been you know
i was here in two stores and
i was hearing something different from
my insurance uh
i was like oh well let's actually leave
you know like instead of going from
instead of like
going from here to directly to another
rehab which is that's the thing that's
the way you do it
you know yeah sorry i'm just gonna go
i'm just gonna go yeah
and i gotta ride and i knew the reason i
was doing it was because i was going to
go home
and come down here
i have a friend that
has basically been just feeding me money
sort of sort of as a uh as a loan
against my tax return refund that's
coming
um so you know that i think the last one
of those transactions was last night
but there's a lot of them you know
that's
basically the main way i've been getting
money um
you know so
you're spiraling yeah i take it
and i i take a hit when i take a hit
like i took a hit earlier
sitting down over there and uh
i take a hit and i blow it out and i say
i love smoking crack i love it
yeah that's what i love to do and uh
you're just not ready to quit yeah it's
like it's like as much as i can do
until it's over you know it's not like
uh okay stop
and then go to rehab it's like as much
as i can do as much as i could do
and you know it's it's really
it's kind of so embarrassing i mean
everything is it's like like the i guess
i'm just at the mo
this is just the most embarrassing i'm
already like that
on your channel right i'm like i'm like
the i mean we call it on
well we can call it honesty i guess well
you're you're you're the most honored
you're one of the most honest you and
maybe
yeah so so the honesty
uh is you know revealing
some just ridiculous embarrassing
behavior yeah and right now i don't even
care
right right now um
you know i'm thinking about you know
someone i met
right before i came in here that like
like i'm in that state
uh one of the girls i just interviewed
is that you're talking about
yeah and she walked out you yeah um
i'd like to you know maybe see what
she's doing later i have a sh
you know um
last night what did i do i got
last night i got you gave me some money
and
someone else gave me some money and then
that was over i went home
and did my thing at home which is just
you know porn or pouring in my bedroom
on my phone just putting crack
which is actually that's like the best
way to do it down here
it's too expensive yeah it's just like
it's like
uh and dangerous the girl the girls on
the on the video
always do like what i want you know
these girls
these girls are enjoying right there
they do they do the thing that i'm that
i'm
wanting them to do but uh so then
your wallet will still be there after
watching porn again it's free
uh which is funny because i don't watch
it i i don't watch porn at all
it's funny people people are surprised
about that
but uh so i so then after that i took a
shower
four in the morning i had twelve dollars
right
so i'm out of it and uh
and uh
i took a bunch of pills like like this
muscle like
like like a relaxer you know like not
not i don't think it's dangerous but
a bunch of them which is contributing to
my
sort of like you know what i mean like
this is different than the crack high
there's a there's like a
yeah you seem a little more relaxed it's
it's like yeah this head yeah yeah
um so i was like
i'm gonna so i have 12 hours i'm home no
car i'm going downtown to get ten
dollars
i like that big hit ten dollars i'm
gonna go downtown get it
find a place to sit yeah like a dark
place against the wall
and do that that was my that was my
whole thing
and i walked far like at four in the
morning
last night there was the buses weren't
running there was no like i
could i can use lift like i'm able to do
lift every whenever
now and there's no lift
i walked really far
i i like walking around looking for
people seeing
seeing what's up you know but i didn't
see a single person until
some like uh basically like a trans
transvestite you know you call it i
don't know like a
transgender transgender like you know
like a
biological male a little female in a van
you know like sees me it's funny that's
like like the reverse of what i
used to do sees me and i could see that
he looked at me
and then like turned and turned around
and came and parked and came next to me
what are you doing you know i'm walking
downtown i'm basically walking downtown
and so i get it we'll get in you know i
get i get into this
van but
uh they just they just drove me like
yeah
nothing happened but i was like i don't
know you know what's gonna happen maybe
we can
do something do some sex thing i don't
know like twelve dollars but
finally after that she dropped me off
like down like a little bit farther down
and then
then a lift guy came and i came out here
and
i got the ten dollar thing from a guy a
guy never i just go to whoever i don't
necessarily like i should probably
should always go to someone i've been to
before but everyone has it down here so
he does the whole thing gives me the ten
like like gets it i see it
like uh
you know puts it into the you know
breaks it gives it to me it's
fine very good i walk away i go do i go
i go find a spot like i said
i sit put it in there
it's not crack oh no it's fake
right and so
it's funny how like that is like
you know just the worst thing that can
happen for
in my life my life has now changed into
that like like
you know anyone would say like the worst
thing what's the worst thing that could
happen uh you know
your your brother your parents die your
kids die you know
no well for me the worst thing that can
happen is like the last hit
is not real and uh so i
immediately just started walking all
around downtown looking for this guy i
still haven't found him
and uh i i was really going to
fight like like be like what i've never
done you know like if he's
if he's riding down the street i my
plan was to be like a like a linebacker
nfl just
sprint out and tackle him and do that
you know see what happens so your life
is getting into
dangerous territory now i don't care
that's the thing i do not care
right like don't care i'm not sure this
is the answer but
are you religious maybe talked about
this like i'm not at all but i
you know i last night i had two
different things happen because we had a
conversation recently
in between our interviews where you and
i talked about maybe maybe
a religious conversion is the is the
answer well i
i do i do i believe in in christ
right like that's what that's how i am
like i read the bible
so um you know i've been
i've said it like a lot like i like
there's no doubt
in my mind that jesus christ you know
is who he says he is right like that
that's real
uh god is real um
so i don't know if it was the time that
the uh
it wasn't it was earlier in the night
earlier in the night when i was down
here
uh there's a guy that sits on a corner
and hands out food for free and all
and wants and and like wants to read a
prayer he's a he's a
christian so he asked me you know i was
walking by i thought
i thought he might not ask me like
because i
maybe i don't look like as homeless as
everybody else but he asked me
i said okay and then he read the thing
it was it was the
it was the the the lord's prayer our
father who i remember
you know so which
you know i recently read a book like a
bunch of times in a row
about that i guess i'm into that you
know
so then
some he wants to pray he wants to pray
for me or we you know he's like repeat
he basically like
had me repeating a prayer like you know
i repent
you know i want you know i do like this
prayer repeating with him and
i start crying right i start crying
and then so then he just continues to
pray for me as i'm crying
right crying and then i had the burrito
and then i went like when i was over i
walked you know
20 feet down and stood there and was
crying
yeah yeah and that's
you know that's i didn't even think of
it until right now that i'm telling you
that that
always for me
the presence of god uh involves me
crying
that's happened probably you know
dozens hundreds maybe of times over the
last
uh 20 years right when it's god and you
know what that is
you who maybe don't believe in god or
what it's love
like you said the first priority it's
that's god is love
yeah those are the same things exactly
so we believe so you say love i say
god we're talking about the same thing
we agree 100 yeah
and so on i went and then uh
so that happened last night and also
last night as i was as i was
walking after taking those pills and
and i'm walking down here i was thinking
maybe god's not real you know maybe
maybe it's not real
good because
you know like
i i wouldn't i wouldn't mind dying you
know i mean like that like
uh i wouldn't i say that i
i wonder if i mean it uh
but the shame you know like like the
shame the embarrassment
like uh honestly like this is kind of
cool but this is putting
this is putting that several levels up
like we're just going like
you know who knows what this is going to
turn into yeah
well i mean back to what you were just
saying about love and god and all that i
think the purest form
of love we're calling it
is self-love because if you're able to
love yourself you're going to love your
children and your
loved ones and your family and everyone
around you yeah in the appropriate way
right that's why i tell like women is oh
i just want to do it for my kids like
you don't do it for your kids
do it for yourself and then your kids
are going to benefit
yeah in the strongest way possible
because you're loving yourself
that's absolutely true and i have zero
love for myself that's right i'm a
monster i'm i'm i'm sick
no you couldn't be doing the things
you're doing yeah if you if you love
yourself
oh i hate myself i despise myself you
know
and common sense is not going to get
through to you because you're you're
you're clearly worthy of loving yourself
and you're loved by everyone around you
i i have a lot of people who love me a
lot yeah
a lot i love you i think you're amazing
and not because you're getting a lot of
views on my channel just because i think
you're a great guy and you deserve
a happier healthier life but i don't
know how to yeah get that into your
skull
right there's a guy that i'm really
close to that is struggling in the same
way
like the same thing except he's like not
as uh he holds it together better
like he doesn't go like like like for
bro so you'll be homeless in the tent
soon
right he doesn't do that right but uh
yeah he does what he does well he has
like a you know he owns a home and has
like a
you know a good job and all that
um so
he yeah so we talk and i talked to him
there's a couple people that i talk to
that's it but i just absolutely
avoid a lot of people
just just don't respond to them i
haven't spoken to my mother
who's just you know i should probably
text her right now
in a month you know
like she was gonna come and help me you
know
yeah and i was happy about that you know
i needed i needed people i needed
someone to come help me i got my
apartment i was just laying there
um just had anyone there to help me
would it would have been and she was
gonna come but then
the night like she's gonna come on a day
then the night before that day
i wound up getting some money somehow
came down
and just was smoking smoking smoking and
uh
wasn't so that she was texting me i
wasn't responding so she did not come
she's like hey
you're smoking yeah i'm not gonna go uh
yeah uh no car
you know doing a lot of bus rides and
and lift rides down here
you know were you coming to skid row
frequently before like before you and i
first met
oh if if i'm using if if i'm cleaning i
never come a skid row
pretty much but like when you're going
down to figaro and picking up girls and
all that
i yeah it depends if if i'm just trying
to just get some drugs go
like if i have a little bit of money i'm
just trying to get high
and that's it i would drive straight
down here
oh you would yeah oh yeah the trade
street it's the same place right
where it's there yeah i've never seen
you here before yeah well yeah
yeah i wouldn't really i would drive and
go and go go home you wouldn't see me
i'd drive get it and
leave i wouldn't be here um if i
if i was going on a can can you get
crack
on figaro street yeah so so that's
another if i was doing that
like that's more of an extended thing
going down there
uh then that down there the people would
start to like recognize me like they'd
start to see me around
you know caught me down there driving
around and
uh just crazy driving around for this
crack the same thing down there as it is
here
so much it's easier to get here well
here it's everything
everywhere everybody has it here you
can't walk a block without down there
down there it's better if you like no
somebody know where to go
uh yeah like it like uh
i don't know if i should say the names
of other other that you should
people that are on this that have been
interviewed by you other people that
have been interviewed by you
uh if you if you do i'll take them out a
friend
yeah i have a friend down there that i
was actually
when i first thought of coming in and
talking today i was thinking like
like bring her too hi like let's talk
together you know i don't know why i was
thinking that
ah let's see
so so so it's fake and now i'm just
walking around looking for this guy
so that i can demand them ten dollars
back and uh
along the way i talked people ask me and
i you know people were like
well at least one guy was like like
backing me up
told me i know i don't know who that guy
is he's over there
and uh i basically did what i've been
doing this whole time is
asking people for money that's how i've
been doing it this time
asking people for money because i don't
have any money and
uh and there's no way there was
it was just like not possible that i was
going to come out here for that last hit
not get it
not get it go home there's no way uh
so i asked one of my closest friends i
give you my name i have to give him you
know give him money she did
and uh then i thought of you i'm here
it's the day
i know you want to interview me let's do
this and uh so i've been
down here um so common sense is not the
answer
because clearly you're sensible and
you're intelligent and i can tell you
that if you continue with this
path you'll end up homeless and then
living in a tent on skid row
well par part of me thinks that's why
that's what should happen
see that's where i think the real core
of the issue is
it's your self-love right and if you
believe you deserve that and that's what
i've that's why
that's what my channel is about people
think my channel is about addiction or
something
it's not it's about self-love okay and
self-love is why these people believe
that skid row is
tolerable or acceptable and you're
starting to have that same mindset of
believing that this would be okay or
this would be what you deserve
what yeah i don't know i don't know if i
think it would be okay
but it would be appropriate yeah see
that that's what i hear with so many
people i've interacted with
where you know women who are looking for
prince charming
and i've basically played that role with
them in their lives not not romantically
necessarily but
yeah but like look i'm gonna help you
get housing and i'll get you
you know you get your life together so
you can do everything you need to do
and they they does it ever work never
never
you know why they smoke crack that's it
like like the first thing or math or
drugs whatever
that's like that's the only thing
it's not like i need a house i need it i
need it so do you believe that drug
addiction is the cause of that behavior
or do you believe the lack of self-love
which leads to drug addiction is the
cause of that behavior
because they were they were they were
abused as children probably
yeah it's like it's like what came first
the chicken or the egg i think for that
you know like they're probably the same
thing in the end
well i mean for me i think the
self-hatred
is pretty very very much
uh connected to the drug addiction yeah
they're that's some say
basically the same thing but in the
beginning like when it started
but if you go to a rehab and you got
clean from the drug you're not cured
you'll relapse 90 of the time 95 percent
yeah
so that's why i suspect drug addiction
is not the real issue it's the self-love
is a real issue
yeah if you frame it that way where self
love is i could throw you in jail for
three months and you'll be clean right
but as soon as you get out you're gonna
march down here uh
maybe not that's that's probably
actually i probably wouldn't
you know but eventually something would
trigger it and you would yeah but event
yeah
the pattern would be eventually i would
come down here yes i'm saying almost it
probably wouldn't be
it probably wouldn't be if i was in jail
for two days
yes immediately you know but three
months ah
you know and i was starting to get there
i would you know whenever i go to rehab
it takes a little while i sleep and eat
sleep and eat and and uh
for some reason i was like throwing up
every like every night
like i eat too much food so that's a
horrible feeling
you wake up in the night you're throwing
up and to go in there
throwing up every night uh i can't
poop for some reason i can't i don't
know why like i realize like i have i
haven't taken a dump in like two days
what's going on here i'm throwing up but
then i
kind of got through that and i started
to get to the just
start just the beginning of the point
where it's like okay
like let's let's get clean let's be
clean let's let's
you know i i got the book yeah i got a
book out of my bag i bought a bunch of
books
and i'm gonna read it like reading that
book would be like something you do
because you're
clean yeah it's actually about that book
uh about the servant on the mount the
great book and i think it was that same
day
that the you know the opportunity to
leave happened
so now um
i am i am
uh try to get into impact
like that's that's that's the plan right
a rehab
impact is like impact is more of a
hardcore rehab
the ones i've been going to are like you
know
not like easy they're basically just
like a different place to sleep you know
you know when they feed you
how long is that for uh well
that one was for five days but if i
would oh shoot
if i would have uh it would have been
like probably 30 days
and then outpatient after that impact's
longer i don't really know everything
about impact i just know that it's
it's it's tough it's probably the type
of place that i need where people are
going to tell me
you know like they're gonna they're not
gonna they're not gonna
like sugarcoat anything with me and uh
yeah i'm gonna have to that's the thing
so if i do that if i go and get clean
uh i'm gonna have to look at some nasty
[ __ ] that that has has uh
been occurring that i've been doing like
nasty like it's just just
it's just bad so well you have the
ability to be honest with yourself and
that's that's a great
skill yeah but but but
that you know i'm being honest with
myself about that
that should have been doing that's
you know that's uh hard
i don't have my i don't have my full
vocabulary today unfortunately
that's rough that's like almost scary
you know
like as i keep saying courage is going
to be the answer
to all these problems that we see on my
channel yeah
anyway so that so i did so like there
you know i did i left that place on
thursday thursday night you know
it so happened that that place impacts
closed
friday through monday monday so i i did
like someone told me what to do i called
friday left the message and
starting tuesday right i got a call
and then every day call until there's a
bed available that's what
that's what you do that's what you do if
you want to go rehab there right
um so
uh i think i will do that i mean
i probably will do that no i i would
urge you to do it yeah i'm going to call
you five times and make sure you do
because because otherwise you're going
to end up yeah your life's going to just
and we'll set it and then so then we'll
be uh
yeah um
yeah man it's just like uh i don't know
what to say mark
i don't know what to say but i'm
actually enjoying myself today
you know i'm having a good time today uh
for what that's worth yeah um
[Music]
what other uh crazy [ __ ] but it's gonna
get worse
without a car you lose the apartment you
lose yeah the apartment
i mean the rent's not paid february um
you know my dad my dad had like eight
grand of my money
paychecks going to him um
and uh i i owe him like i don't even
know the number i owe him
some money well we have an agreement
where i pay him every month you know i
said i pay like three what what like 365
times 17 payments or however much that
is
and uh when he was going to pay the rent
you know uh when i left and
then i just went and smoked so he he did
the right thing actually said you know i
did not pay the rent
i took the entire day you know like i
put you know whatever i'm
like that i i took your money for that
um yeah like you said i'm finally gonna
i'm gonna do i'm gonna finally do what
you're telling me
is where is impact location pasadena
yeah i'll make sure you get there
tomorrow
or whenever they go yeah yeah but it's i
love highland park
it packs in pasadena you call me i'll
give you an uber ride or whatever you
need yeah
i got a lot yeah i got a lot of people
like to do that uh
yeah uh i think that might be the
good first step
yeah i mean yeah
so having kind of established a pattern
of coming down here and i realized that
somehow
like somehow with venmo i i can i could
use lift even though
if my balance is nothing so i'm lifting
down your boom
and i made a rule for myself
here's the rule do not take a hit
down here go home all right go home
because if you take a hit down here
i take it down here
i'm in a tent you know it's gone
you know it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
and uh that's the rule i even i even
tell some of the guys that i get that i
get it from
that's my rule you know that's my rule
and uh i think i followed it once
yeah yeah i just give money away
and if you end up down here it's a
fantasy thing you know it's
it's like there's no self-love nobody
loves me
i i hate me and i hit a crack
it makes it seem like that's not the
case makes it seem like
that all goes away that like like
somebody wants me like
like yeah you know i could i can uh
you know like i'm powerful like
i'm i'm i'm uh
chasing these girls i think they've done
studies i think portugal they did this
where they they took addicts and they
put them in social situations where they
had like
they made friends and you know there was
maybe love in their lives
in some form and that was much
more effective in fighting addiction
then yeah
than anything else well that's what
that's that is like how that is now the
12th step
you know i haven't that i know i know a
lot i have a lot of people like that
in my life you know we're all
all clean we support each other
there for each other um and i am in that
i
am like i'm part of that when i'm clean
but then
take a hit it's a good you know i'm out
i'm out all i can tell you is so you
have this one negative
character flaw there's a positive
character flaw in you
[Music]
that balances that out i don't know what
it is maybe you do maybe you do maybe
you don't but i guarantee you there's
something positive about you that's just
as powerful as this negative
that's true i know that's true
but i feel like that's like
not relevant somehow not today
but it might be enough for a while it
might be you know
but yeah like uh
you know i could have about 42 years old
you know and that
makes me that's that that disgusts me
i'm 42 years old and i actually actually
you know i didn't even think about it
but as i was walking
earlier looking for the guy that sold me
the tip that you know
robbed me uh my birthday's coming up i'm
gonna be 43 years old
like this month and uh
you know i haven't done anything i mean
i've done a lot of stuff but i haven't
like done
anything so shame is a big part of all
this you know like the things people do
like the things that are fun
you know one of the one of the uh
lyft drivers as we were coming down here
was like just talking to me and talking
to me about like the app
late night after uh in koreatown how
crazy it is how
fun it is and like everything's there
and uh
you know people have fun together
through your life whether it's like
partying or whatever or or clean
or with family or whatever and
instead of like i was thinking about
like because korean town's over there
and that they're probably having a lot
of fun and girls and
you know fun like and i've never done
any of that ever in my life
i come over here you know i think like
korean town's over there
and we're driving this way where the
crack is that's
it yeah that's it
you discovered crack at what age i
discovered a crack
uh i think i was like 19 or 20.
um it was it was
like a weird sex addiction thing i don't
know sex addiction
i'm sure it's a sex diction now like in
a weird way but uh
you know i was intrigued by prostitutes
when i discovered that that was
even a thing that existed i don't know
why you know
uh you know that was like that was like
the only that was like the only good
time in my life like like
my senior year high school was was like
awesome
like the most fun i was friends with
everybody i did everything it was like
that was like the one time in my life
where like
you know this is great yeah this is
where everything is succeeding and
i you know being with girls um
but you go down the prostitutes for some
fun i don't even know why i go down
there
and pomona i'm going like down to pomona
that's where this all happened
and uh they were feeling crack and i
think i talked about this in the first
video
yeah so that's how i discovered it like
didn't even know it existed didn't even
know it was a thing and then and then
once i
felt once once i felt that feeling
uh yeah that was that
and so that's been the story you know
it's like
you know i when i when i'm clean i've
told the story
the story seemed different like seemed
like oh yeah he uh
you know he went to school he went he
traveled
you know moved he uh yeah yeah he has a
good job he's a good job here good job
there
but really it's like the whole the whole
story of life is
is this this is this everything is this
yeah so
yeah it's crazy like i like i as soon as
i
as soon as i finish and i don't have any
it's like my mind it's automatically
just
on my phone i'm like where can i get
money i gotta get money somewhere i'll
find money somewhere
you know i'll do it uh
[Music]
yeah so
yeah take a hit on the street see a girl
you know and think maybe i can get a
[ __ ] from that girl
and it's like why no
that's not
it's not her because she's the nearest
one about the crack it changes that
you know i've been out here you know on
the sidewalk
yeah just like what am i doing i'm going
to try to make sure you go to
impact as soon as possible got a call
tomorrow
yeah i've have people on that excellent
that sounds a great plan
what else to stay out of trouble in the
meantime
yeah well i'm gonna i'm gonna try to
finish strong
oh my god yeah i will fall i will fall
asleep i can tell that the uh
how many days you've been up not that
long uh
i've been i woke up on saturday at 4 p.m
from that was like the only that's the
only sleep i had
since leaving that place it was like
saturday
all day still for like from five in the
morning until 4 p.m
uh yeah so i'm like i'm in a similar
state to when i was here
first time um today's monday so
yeah um
yeah i'll uh
i'll see what's going on with uh you
know
so what's going on don't get in a fight
out there yeah no no
oh yeah i was actually like like looking
forward to fighting i've never
had no no no no no no that guy don't
want to get the fight down here
i don't know i don't understand people
find out here but i was out and i was
even thinking like
this this is going to be like a a a day
to be remembered when that white guy
like that crackhead white boy that walks
around went crazy
and you know like like i'd be remembered
for that i was thinking that i was gonna
try to do it it really ends the way you
plan it
yeah i i it's as funny as you know
walking through
super bad neighborhoods like what
doesn't i don't care
you know i walked by a guy near near my
apartment last night like
hey where you from you know he was like
a
gang member yeah like
yeah i don't care no you're getting
indirectly
behavior here yeah
all right patrick well thank you so much
for coming in again and i hope we do
many more of these and i hope you
show some improvement and and i'd love
to thanks for helping me out too
i'd love to document you yeah getting
your your [ __ ] together
however you figure out about it well you
know yeah like like that's
is it gonna be that which that's
happened every time
so but this is like different so i don't
know but that's always happened i got my
[ __ ] together
or uh
it's hard to imagine coming down here
and like living out here or die
or death somehow yeah
so patrick here we are the next morning
after our your talk yesterday
yeah this is tuesday now what uh how'd
it go yesterday
what happened last night well i had fun
during the day uh
i was thinking i was gonna have a super
fun
super fun thing last night had like
plenty of money and
a lot of crack and uh
i got uh tackled and mugged
you know uh which has never happened
that's skid row at night
yeah two guys uh i was talking to a girl
like i tend to do
you had the whole plan i was sitting on
the curb
i had you know i had as much money as
much crack as i would ever have on me
down here and that was like that's like
exciting
but like i didn't i
being up for so long my brain didn't
compete there's two guys standing like
like i seem like i think everybody's
nice
and well the one guy pinned me down
i struggled like i did a decent job
struggling took the money in the crack
and i went from having like as good of
a in my mind right as much fun as i
could possibly have
to being broke no money no crack
oh yeah i'm sorry yeah yeah
so other memories so january and now
february has been
a rough rough ride for you
all right well patrick i wish you the
best of luck
i think i think rehab is probably a
great first step and
i'll try to make sure that happens for
you okay
thank you for being so honest what else
happened you're one of the most honest
people that i've interviewed it takes a
lot of courage to do that my boy john
i'm from new bedford not going to be
happy with me
i'll leave out the crazy i'll leave out
the crazy details what are you doing
don't do that i mean i don't know like
this is
i mean it is what it is and this is
becoming a thing
like like like chronicling well i think
keeping it hidden and pretending it's
not happening
is what gives it this power that
undermines your life i don't really keep
it hidden
but i don't like tell you don't
tell
being a platform like like this is a
very powerful way of
i guess you're right keeping it hidden
from because you talk to your one-on-one
to your therapist
is that right i don't know i tell people
but might tell my people what's going on
what happens
so yeah i guess okay for whatever reason
i ran into you
this time which is by far the worst time
ever by far
and i have done this
why did that happen who knows things
happen
things happen yeah well i'm i'm up to
i'm optimistic for your future
all right well thank you so much and
we'll uh we'll
until next time don't smell crap thanks
you